if my man doesn't like it or agree with it
I'm not doing it
I know there are Gen z's out there screaming right now
but that's my man
that's my fiance
that's my best friend
that my life partner
we're each others forever
why would I do something that my man doesn't agree with or want me to do
I don’t know where things got misunderstood in this generation
but your partner is supposed to be above everyone
above everything
why would you do something that they don't agree with
or makes them feel uncomfortable
they have your best interest at heart
so you know it's coming from a good place
when they tell you
I don't think you should do that
you shouldn't do it
do you understand
like they have your best interest at heart
plain and simple
if my man doesn't like it
I'm not doing it
if he doesn't agree with it
it’s out of basic respect and the relationship
I don’t know where things got lost in translation